okay [ __ ] we're going to be playing
send in the clowns booty that booty oh
that booty what the hell happened what
the [ __ ] is going on remember Oh shine
I'm in car to me what happened to me oh
yeah you're feeling you affected my
irradiated thanks blow what while you
were out I gave you can flow Iranian
with my homemade particle I guess I got
good candy they drink it myself but he
had ionia frog his problem I think you
can use Jesus join me I feel so so
amazing like really great it's getting
crazy speed you're Frank allow you to
throw fireballs make it impervious to
harm another side effect ok ok oh my god
now you're ready to go after done you're
not kidding for once I'm hearing wrong
huh where are you
I've got it your location now taking off
like a guy treading among mere mortals
the leader of the case get out to find
their to track you lieutenant ok ok
Jesus the King guardian for making way
for new gun Jimmy you [ __ ] this as fast
seriously bury me this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
ass cuz really you're not even a friend
much less a close one you can hear my
yeah yeah I'm in your head give me outta
here quick before I see it it's too late
Jimmy who's the damn foam
ok
yeah they got I pick a fast car miser
might shut up with a [ __ ] bone
okay in fact I'm flying
here but no gas he said that hey I looks
like I got [ __ ] off these curtains oh
sure
a shadow
I hear those veterans
house
huh is getting out but it's kind of slow
Kimmy toba Cancer Care way for any sign
of the life finding finding my foot up
your ass we don't stop with the
monologues come on I don't worry I go
come on come on all right I got it go I
don't over the radio there's loud noise
coming from Planet cave I'll be under
posed to the whole way like a hairy guy
here you go oh sure I had to scratch my
neck [ __ ] i got like bugs on my neck I
can't [ __ ] draw it shares a [ __ ]
spider my neck that's [ __ ] up okay oh
oh oh
thank goodness is any real college
[ __ ] wheels okay okay here i got here
come out here surprise
touch chef
we're to catch up with the time Jimmy I
can I kind of kill this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay here we go
there we go
okay this [ __ ] it's like too accurate
[ __ ] show
ok it's not another one yeah okay
where's my car
fierce desire clerk hartsburg one top am
a garage fridge while I'm get tagged by
the military you gotta hurry don't worry
I'll be there soon [ __ ] and I lose
[ __ ] her on
oh oh oh oh
[ __ ] is [ __ ] far
what happened
how am I getting tired but who brings in
the power to half ass job no time to
stop peers and Johnny need me okay Kent
Kent comp [ __ ] get out the way oh good
am I come on here we got you some real
[ __ ] things
look for TAC at the bridge just on
bridge
not a murderer lunch is all way down
there Jesus hey van con dingo mandando
King Gandhi content on bama don't engage
ntaganda
[ __ ] that if all site yeah but we're
stagger 980 who's that guy that's Pierce
yeah she just looks like a fat cat damn
it
[ __ ] an excellent [ __ ] right here
ok
it seems like very precise Jesus
00 can I get up [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
drunk cuz all I am where's that wrong oh
they're up there here's how do I get up
to you get climbed up the side but don't
worry called boys and they're flying in
the chopper good call ok I'm out of
powers where's my talking there we go
now get in here
so much faster [ __ ] do this
ok ok ok calm a chef
hey yo good hell yeah dad that's I know
[ __ ] snipers uh no [ __ ] room okay
calm down
gosh at a chef
okay good good oh there's more since
there's more like what Burfoot careful
up there I'm seeing helicopters fly-in
no [ __ ] knock out or not in this
joint
yeah that's a lot of [ __ ] travelers
it's actually getting insane here it's
getting cold
okay I
wow ok yet gut gut
okay where's the rest of them okay
hey no more times hello meeting new
people I did it we did it
come on match
Johnny come on man I'm trying to talk to
you now you want to try to reason with
seas feel I know I know Johnny but we
can make it right kiss him kiss him yeah
will you friend Johnny good friend yeah
yeah muscle muscle penis muscle penis
god I can't answer test let's get you
back home stripper Oh once my man
stripper pole oh sure and so ends the
tale of our intrepid hero
bound by the
find the game
hey I gotta steal food is safe once
again who knows when the saints
hold on to protect Gemma e n ? haha [ __ ]
okay well thanks a lot check miles back
down
dicks out for Harambee